uh this is really amazing this will
really be
as far as i know this is really the
final cpac segment for the week okay so
just uh
bear that in mind we covered cpac we
covered the speeches we covered trump's
lie riddled speech from sunday already
i'm not doing that again
it was brought to my attention that on
fox news as soon as donald trump started
telling his election lies during his
speech
fox put up a disclaimer
clearly meant to avoid another potential
lawsuit over donald trump's obviously
demonstrably false claims about who won
the 2020 election the disclaimer that
popped up on the screen on fox news when
trump started lying about who won
said quote the voting system companies
have denied the various allegations made
by president trump and his counsel
regarding the 2020 election let's look
at and listen to a video if you're not
watching as soon as trump starts telling
the lies
the disclaimer pops up on the screen on
election night we did so much better
than they ever thought in their wildest
imagination that they just said the hell
with it let it go
what they did
what they did
i'm also leading
in the polls against harris
because not a lot of people think that
joe's going to be running but you never
know this is a strange world
and everyone else is going to run on the
radical left whether it's
on the democrat side or the re i love my
republicans but we're really kicking
their ass too
but we love them
but we like it because they're friends
of ours right so it's okay i think we
can say that affectionately
no they're great they're great and
they're working hard that is really
something else but it's also relevant
that the disclaimer is pathetically weak
the voting system companies have denied
the allegations of trump about the
election it's not just the voting system
companies have denied it there is no
evidence for it 60 lawsuits have been
thrown out there have been audits and
re-audits and so-called audits and
hearings and re-hearings and there
should be
uh
a statement that says there is no
evidence whatsoever of election fraud
that would impact the results in even a
single state so on the one hand it's
notable that fox news now that they are
under lawsuit from dominion and we'll
get to that in a second they're putting
up this disclaimer as soon as trump
starts lying but then the other part of
this the other side of this is the
disclaimer is pathetically weak it's a
disclaimer that basically puts trump's
claims of fraud
and dominions denials of fraud on the
same footing right it's okay so trump is
claiming fraud and dominion voting
systems has denied the fraud it's kind
of like a both sides thing fox news is
saying
we're telling you what each side is
saying and that's it but if you do news
you should be able to say
there is absolutely no evidence of what
donald trump is claiming here it's not
just trump claims and dominion denies
and in fact it's not just fear of
lawsuits that's at play fox news is
being sued fox news is being sued by
dominion voting systems and not only
that not only that in this very same
lawsuit just a few days ago dominion
voting systems has subpoenaed rudy
giuliani
sydney powell and my pillow ceo mike
lindell in that very lawsuit so this is
very actively very real
but it's still a really weak disclaimer
if fox news had guts or any concern for
journalistic integrity they would say
the election was won fairly by president
biden contrary to donald trump's claims
the election was won fairly by joe biden
there is no evidence at all that
supports donald trump's claims instead
they do this pathetic
flaccid weak disclaimer but
the fact that they're doing it at all we
know why it's because of what's going on
legally at this point in time
we're following the lawsuit there's been
no real news on it
recently they've sent these subpoenas to
rudy sydney powell and mike lindell we
don't know what's actually going to
happen as far as their involvement in
the suit goes but we will keep you
posted about it but fox news doing the
absolute minimum it's sort of like a
back page
retraction that nobody sees but the
newspaper hopes clears them legally
that's what fox news is doing here
if your job requires you to know what
people are talking about online or
you're just curious what's being
discussed online check out thought
leaders which has an awesome data
platform that scrapes through youtube
podcasts newsletters every day and
analyzes what is in the content and then
they turn that data into customizable
graphs whether that's a brand a person a
topic anything else you want to explore
companies can see where their
competitors have been mentioned
marketers can see what trends are on the
rise before planning strategy or content
creators like me can see what topics and
themes are being featured on other shows
for example you can see here i can track
what podcasts are discussing the midterm
elections or i can see how many youtube
channels are talking about rudy giuliani
or i can even see what shows have
mentioned me by searching my own name
and you can use this for free
that's free forever sign up today create
your own instant thought leaders trends
report now the link is down below